dann begrüßte sie zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir uns zunächst ein paar
gedanken machen wollen über mögliche
haus arbeitsthemen und sie haben sie
bestimmt schon gesehen
ich gehe noch mal kurz darauf ein also
das sind jetzt mögliche oberthemen sie
können natürlich dann wenn sie eines
davon bearbeiten gern noch spezieller
dieses thema angehen und auch gerne den
titel noch etwas spezifischer wählen
also zum beispiel können sie sich mit
dem verhältnis der vier ursachen nach
aristoteles beschäftigen das ist eine
möglichkeit
und sie können gerne auch also das ist
natürlich das sind wir nicht so intensiv
darauf eingegangen aber wenn sie sich
jetzt mit der antiken philosophie besser
aus sondern auseinandergesetzt schon
haben oder besser auskennen können sie
das gerne nehmen dann glaube ich ein
ganz zentrales thema wo wir auch sehr
viel zeit mitgebracht haben dass es der
youtube seine kritik des kausal begriffs
also diese kausal analyse der wie die
jungs frage ist es eine empirische
kritik bin ich mir gar nicht mal so
sicher dass es basiert natürlich auf
seinem empirismus aber ich glaube er
macht auch sehr viele begriffs
analytische beobachtungen wie wir jetzt
gleich noch sehen werden bei david luiz
dem zweiten der heutigen sitzung weil
der sich auf eine passage bei david hume
bezieht die allerdings gar nicht aus
seinem traktat stammt den wir ja hier
gelesen haben sondern aus allen später
erschienen
kurzen kürzeren bemerkungen dazu also
wenn sie sich mit der widmung
beschäftigen dann würde ich ihnen raten
auch noch andere werke von ihm
hinzuzuziehen
die ich dann aber bei zeit auch noch in
diesen dropbox ordner stellenwert wir
haben sie alle zugriff zu diesem ordner
also da würde ich den dann in den ordner
primär literatur hineinkopieren dann in
meine kanzlei zentraler qualitätsbegriff
das ist auch eine spannende sache
natürlich auch ein kompliziertes thema
da wäre es dann sinnvoll dass auch
abzugrenzen von theorien wie zum
beispiel von david hume die die die den
qualitätsbegriff im touristisch
kritisierten wie kann also zum beispiel
auf der video antwort das wäre eine
spannende frage
dann den john leslie mackie und seine
enos bedingung die wir ja in der letzten
vorletzten sitzung auch noch ausführlich
diskutiert haben da wäre es mir
wichtiger bei diesen moderneren denken
dass sie hier im immer auch mehr
problematisieren das wären wir also ganz
wichtig weil eben bei diesen klassischen
themen es ihr darauf ankommt dass sie
verstehen dass sie also zum beispiel
kann es theorie muss man erst mal
ausgiebig verstehen das ist weder ist
sehr viel hermeneutische gefordert und
bei diesen also auch bei aristoteles
muss natürlich viel verstehen was
bedeutet jetzt dass hier das hier
da würde ich sagen kritik dann wirklich
ganz am schluss während bei diesen
neueren denken die einfach uns auch
zeitlich viel näher stehen weil sie zeit
teilweise noch leben oder eben erst vor
kurzem verstorben sind da ist es dann
noch wichtiger zu kritisieren also bei
mac i ganz klar die frage klappt das mit
dieser bedingung ich habe da auch noch
ein paar ideen in der retten
zusammenfassung formuliert ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher ob das zutrifft also
mir leuchtet die theorie immer noch
nicht ganz ein also intuitiv ist schon
klar wenn man mal genau hinschauen
findet ihr wieder man kommt dann wieder
auf dasselbe problem wenn man ins detail
geht dann wiederholt sich das ganze
dass man also je mehr man mit der lupe
hinschaut immer wieder dieselbe struktur
findet so wie sie es zum beispiel bei
kristallen häufig finden oder bei sie
kennen vielleicht diese fraktale also
selbst ähnliche figuren wenn sie damit
der lope hinschauen dann sehen sie die
grobstruktur die sie mit der lupe
betrachten sehen sie wieder kehren im
detail und wir mehr sie schauen immer
wieder so ein bisschen was scheint mit
der thematik enthalten zu sein aber das
ist kann man wirklich diskutieren und
mir wäre es wichtig dass sie also wenn
sie einen der neueren texte nehmen eben
beginnend jetzt mit mecki oder am mit
russell dann können sie auch gern nehmen
dass sie hier eben viele eigene
beispiele entwickeln dass sie das ganze
problematisieren das darstellen ist das
eine das ist er in der antiken oder
mittelalterlichen oder eben 19
philosophie wichtigen oder das
interpretieren hier wären mir wichtig
dass problematisieren das
experimentieren da sie mal gedanken
gedankenexperiment unternehmen und sagen
könnte es nicht auch ganz anders
aussehen
was wäre denn wenn da sieht hier noch
mehr in der diskussion eingehen
wie gesagt mecki scheint mir auf russell
zu antworten
also was könnte da noch so ein bisschen
drin vorkommen russell können sie
natürlich auch zum gegenstand eines
einzigen einer einzigen hausarbeit
machen aber mir scheint man noch ein
bisschen interessanter zu sein
dann donnert davidson auf dem wir heute
noch einmal zu sprechen kommen
schwieriger text bei donald davidson
weil erst mal nicht ganz klar ist was
eigentlich will
da kommen ja viele sprach philosophische
beobachtungen mit rein und wir lesen ja
kausalität ihren theologischen fragen
was ist jetzt genau das für eine
beziehung oder logisch oder wir fragen
uns was sind denn jetzt ursachen sind
dass kräfte usw dann david luiz
qualitätsbegriff den würden heute auch
noch ein bisschen behandeln und der
nächsten sitzung die noch mal machen und
diesen kim über eben nicht kausale
beziehungen um das sind also die neueren
wo sie eben sehr viel diskutieren können
bei david luiz
ganz wichtig das contra faktische also
wenn das nicht gewesen wäre dann wäre
auch das nicht gewesen
david luiz ist eigentlich so der große
denker des contra faktischen das ist so
dieses stichwort was mit diesen denke
hier verbindung steht der ist glaube ich
im jahr 2001 verstorben
der ist nicht allzu alt geworden aber
ein sehr sehr bedeutender denkt hat der
in der angelsächsischen welt total in
ist und total prominent ist
das ist ein denker aus princeton und im
print cent denken die alles so wie er
immer was wäre wenn und wenn das nicht
gewesen wäre was wäre dann
da ist princeton berühmt berüchtigt
dafür also und das ist jetzt aber der
donald davidson und der ist ein aufsatz
geschrieben course relations und der ist
1981 erschienen
und der mann ist sehr alt geworden und
auch sehr einflussreich und zwar ist das
ein denker der etwas die brücke schlagen
kann von der angelsächsischen allzu
analytischen philosophie hin zur
europäischen continental david dieser
donald davidson immer zitierten wenn es
darum geht zur verbindung herzustellen
dann ist das der bezugspunkt drei sätzen
und wir gehen jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen darauf ein wir haben ein paar
leitfragen also wie knüpft davidson an
mexikos bedingungen an welche
sprachliche form haben nach neuen
davidson kausal aussagen qualitäts
behauptungen und dann weg und theologie
liegt davidsons ansatz zugrunde
also davidson das kann ich schon
vorwegnehmen davidson mag diese
ereignisse das wird er sehr passend also
ereignisse anzunehmen wenn man jetzt
über ereignisse rät dann muss natürlich
auch die ereignisse in ein angenehm an
angemessene sprachliche form bringen
jetzt geht sie eben um so was wie
singuläre terminieren die sind zu
unterscheiden von generellen termini und
jetzt lesen wir einfach noch mal hier
ist ein bisschen reinen den text wir
hatten eher das jetzt in der letzten
sitzung schon ein bisschen behandelt
also es geht mir in diesem aufsatz um
die schlichte frage welche logische form
singuläre kausale aussagen haben zum
beispiel die überschwemmungen
verursachte die hungersnot der durchstoß
verursachte caesars tod der brand im
stall verursachte dass das schwein
gegrillt wurde die frage hier ist
bescheidener als etwa die frage nach der
wahrheit singulärer kausal aussagen oder
die frage ob diese aussagen mit hilfe
eines kausalen jung kurs zu analysieren
sein entscheidender ist sie deshalb weil
sich schon beantwortet ist wird wie
herausgefunden haben welche logische
oder grammatikalische rolle
die wörter oder satzteile in den
beispielsätzen spielen und wird diese
aufgabe können wir auf umständliche
definition oder aktualisierung
verzichten werden das letzte mal darüber
diskutiert wie sieht es jetzt aus wenn
man sagt die überschwemmung verursacht
die hungersnot ist es jetzt diese
überschwemmung hier also diese konkrete
hier oder einfach die überschwemmung und
dann hatten wir eben gesagt ja gut wenn
man das jetzt mal auf dieses nächste
beispiel bei caesar bezieht dann ist es
eben so ein eigenname es gibt eben nur
diesen einen cesar der von fotos oder
wem auch immer
den verschwörern ermordet wurde als er
geht es immer um diese spezielle also
index kalisch diese überschwemmung uhr
sagte diese hungersnot dieser durchstoß
dessen tod als um das ganz konkrete ja
also das ist so die perspektive und wie
verstehen sie jetzt wenn wir jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen drüber reden
das anliegen von davidson was möchte
jetzt machen was möchte er nicht machen
diese korrekt sind
wie er genau welche logische oder
kanadischer rolle die wörter oder
satzteile in den beispielsätzen spielen
und und diese frage sei bescheiden als
die nach der wahrheit säkuläre kausal
aussagen
was verstehen sie darunter der wahrheit
das könnte man darunter verstehen also
die wahrheit' bedingungen die wahrheit
funktion sie kennt diese war heizwert
tabellen sowas oder man könnte darunter
versteht die verifizierbar kite als und
will das überhaupt
also als wahr erwiesen werden kann diese
ist ja alles pro positionen hat das sind
ja alles wahrheit' wertige cw-wert
fähige setzte also die verifizierbar
kite könnte man damit meint es klappt
meinte aber nicht und dann noch ob diese
aussagen mit hilfe eines kausalen jung
tors zu analysieren zahlen was verstehen
sie hier drunter
was könnte man da welche frage ist damit
gemeint
ich glaube auch also diese kleine diese
ewige frage ist jetzt kausalität also
die ursache hinreichend oder notwendig
oder beides oder ist es eben ist eben
nicht hinreichend aber eben notwendiger
teil einer bedingung die daneben
zusammengenommen hinreichend ist also
ich glaube diese frage das ist diese
frage nach dem kausalen jung tor
und die will auch nicht so sehr
betrachten wir einfach die logische oder
grammatikalische rolle oder satzteile
der wörter oder satzteile betrachten
jetzt wollen wir schauen wir das hier
also macht jetzt lesen wir hier nochmal
weiter er sagt jung david hume verfolgt
kann man eine ursache definieren als
zitat einen gegenstand den man andere
erfolgt wobei allen gegenständen die dem
ersten gleichartig sind gegenstände
folgen die dem zweiten gleichartiges
sind diese definition war es ziemlich
eindeutig darauf hin dass ursachen und
wirkung entitäten sind durch singuläre
ausdrücke benannt oder beschrieben
werden können und zwar es sind sie
vermutlich ereignisse denn die einen
können den anderen folgen
ok andererseits schreibt ein traktat
unter der überschrift regeln nach denen
ursachen und wirkungen erkannt werden
das systemische frage dass während es
davor er die tories oder und
theologische war dass dort wo mehrere
voneinander verschiedene gegenstände
dieselbe wirkung hervorrufen würden ein
moment dass ich in gleicher weise bei
ihnen allen findet die wirkung
vermittelt der gleiche wirkung gleiche
ursachen voraussetzen so müssen wir den
verschiedenen faktor stets in dem
umstand suchen indem sie so viel wir zu
erkennen vermögen miteinander
übereinstimmen
hier scheint das moment qualität bzw der
umstand zur konstanz eines ereignisses
die ursache zu sein und nicht das
ereignis selbst denn dieses ist nur
unter manchen aspekten
wie andere ereignisse unter anderen
aspekten ist es verschieden für die
vermutung bei jungs sei nicht ereignis
sondern faktoren die ereignisse näher
spezifizieren die eigentlichen ursachen
spricht auch dass bei ihm kausale
aussagen niemals notwendig war sind
würden nämlich ereignisse als ursachen
von tieren und während die einen wären
wäre ein eigenes denkmal das als zitat
die ursache von b zu kennzeichnen wäre
und angenommen ein solches ereignis
existiert wirklich dann folgt logisch
dass rosa von baby hat was findet er
jetzt hier bei david jung vor war
inwiefern bezieht er sich jetzt hier auf
david jugend was ist hier noch
interessant die sind total
ja
gegenstände selber reden so der abt
gesammelt
genau als das erste wäre das erste wäre
da sagt dagegen statt
wir hatten uns objekt war das im
englischen text und wir haben uns
gefragt ja was für eine ökologie ist
jetzt dieses objekt und dann hatten wir
auch so wie es jetzt davidson hier tut
gesagt es sind wahrscheinlich ereignisse
ereignisse und die können ereignisse
sind individuell bar ereignisse sind mit
singulären termini bezeichnet war dieses
ereignis zu diesem zeitpunkt hier
und die sind auch voneinander zu trennen
die sind ganz klar aufeinander das sind
ja ein anderes ereignis kann diesen
ersten ereignis folgen sagt er hier wo
jetzt schreiben
das ist so unklar
dass es nicht stimmt das wünsche ich
ihnen geschieht
also es gibt noch es gibt noch eine
andere passage auf die kommen wir noch
wenn wir jetzt in der zweiten hälfte der
heutigen sitzung auf david luiz zu
sprechen kommen da gibt es noch eine
andere formulierung dieser kausalität
relation bei der youtube die gerade in
die andere richtung geht dann ist eine
contra faktische formulierung geht also
wir müssen jetzt das nicht in jeder
hinsicht weiter verfolgen aber sauber
hier
wir haben die ursache und und wie ist es
hier mit gleichen wirkungen
was weist ihr punkt also das eben
gleiche wirkungen gleiche ursachen
voraussetzen ist es in ihrer sicht
problematisch da können wir uns mal
überlegen stimmt das
es sagt viel aus
ja das ist das ist ein zitat von jugend
ja genau
das ist die sogenannte regula ried
theorie aber jetzt schauen wir noch mal
auf dieses beispiel bei diesen hausbank
ich meine es gibt natürlich immer das
problem der multiplen realisierbarkeit
das ist das worauf sie wahrscheinlich
ansprechen also die wirkung hätte von
audi hätte auch von bewirkt werden
können also es ist so
das ist nur hinreichend dafür aber nicht
notwendig ne also es könnte könnten
beliebige andere sachen das aussehen das
ist die so genannte multiple
realisierbarkeit aber jetzt ist halt
immer die frage wie wir betrachten das
ist wieder so ein bisschen der punkt das
letzte mal
wir können natürlich die wirkung so
spezifisch betrachten so spezifisch das
eben nur eine ursache dafür oder eine
anti cds bedingung dafür infrage kommt
wenn wir zeigen eben genau dieser
hausbrand in dieser spezifischen form
wäre es vielleicht denkbar in so
spezifisch zu fassen diesen hausbahn
dass es eben nur eine ganz bestimmte
ursache sein konnte die ihn so
verursacht hat es war so ein bisschen
unser problem reden wir jetzt einfach
davon dass das haus brennt natürlich das
haus kann auf ganz verschiedene weise in
brand gesetzt worden
der junge ist eben ein klassiker der
eben häufig kanonisch verwendet wir
werden aber bei david luiz nachher noch
eine andere passage bei youtube sehen
die kontrast die das ganze contra
faktisch das wäre ja konto faktisch
läuft auch so ein bisschen ins ins ins
in die notwendige bedingung rein aber
wir wollen es erstmal glaube ich so
lassen
ich glaube was er hier eben meint ist so
was wie eine regula ried theorie in eine
reguläre theorie ja das ist eben die
sieben arten von sun city
den zuschlag
ihre eigenschaften
eine eigenschaft
hier werden
ja so könnte man es vielleicht genau
dass man einfach sagt wir fassen dass
hier alles zusammen hör alle möglichen
hinreichenden bedingungen fassen wir
unter ein zusammenhang so sind generell
ein terminus dann regula riet er aber
die schule ist durchaus
interpretationsbedürftig das stimmt und
jetzt gibt es noch eine zweite wahl
zweite form das haben wir schon gesagt
wo es ihr im moment eine qualität oder
ein umstand ist was ein ereignis zu
einer ursache macht mehr
das ist dann eher das dann nicht so sehr
die sind nicht ist nicht so sehr die
ereignisse selbst sondern faktoren die
die ereignisse mehr spezifizieren
so könnte man es verstehen ja als es
wäre dann wieder ihr die situation also
also die frage ist jetzt die bei mac i
bei mac i geht es ja nicht so sehr jetzt
mehr um ereignis speziellen es geht also
dass die ursache ist schon ein ereignis
also zum beispiel der kurzschluss aber
der kurzschluss steht ja in einer
komplexeren anti cds bedingungen in
dieser diesem gefüge
also wir haben dann die ursache und die
ursache kommt hier noch in eine
konjunktion mit anderen faktoren mit
hinein zum beispiel eben dass es
brennbares material daneben gab und dass
keine feuerlöschanlage auch noch da war
ja das könnte man vielleicht so sehen
als so eine art an
also art factor oder situation also die
frage ist immer sind ursachen jetzt
ereignisse oder sind ursachen ihr
situationen und situation könnte man so
beschreiben kommt jetzt gerade als
ereignisse in einem bestimmten kontext
mit bestimmten kontext bedingungen das
würde ich jetzt mal als situation
bezeichnen die situation ist ja kein
ereignis so eine situation enthält ein
ereignis und noch eine randbedingungen
so will ich das formulieren
[Musik]
genau das macht er jetzt auch gleich
also er möchte er möchte jedenfalls eher
ereignisse als kandidaten ausmachen
mit dieser sprachlichen struktur und
jetzt gehen wir mal ein bisschen weiter
er sagte hier wenn man bestimmte
ereignisse als bedingungen bezeichnet
stiftet man damit nur verwirrung
vielleicht sind jedoch ursachen gar
keine ereignisse wie der kurzschluss im
falle von mackie oder meier's sturz von
der leiter soll entsprechen
hier setzen wie die tatsache dass dieser
kurzschluss auftrat oder die tatsache
dass meyer von der leiter viele sätze
können wahrheit' bedingungen für andere
setzt ausdrücken daher das wort
bedingung satz oder konditionell also
das ist jetzt hier so ein bisschen die
sprachliche bildung auf seite 82 die
jetzt hier vornimmt
[Musik]
all das ist jetzt die frage da sitzt er
unter logische frage wir reden wir jetzt
am besten über kausale ereignisse oder
grausamen bedingungen vielleicht besser
kausale bedingung sind kausale bedingung
jetzt kommt nämlich auf die sprachliche
form an sind kausale bedingungen am
ehesten durch ereignisse durch
ereignisse beschrieben oder nicht ihr
durch sätze oder tatsachen sachverhalt
ja also an dritte merken noch dazu eine
interessante ist dass wir jetzt hier
offensichtlich über tatsachen sprechen
möchte über tatsachen sachverhalten er
bringt nämlich jetzt hier so 1 1 einen
interessanten satz und das ist jetzt das
hier wenn ursachen ihr setzte als setzen
als singulären ausdrückt entsprechen
wäre die logische form eines satzes wie
erstens der kurzschluss verursachte den
brand und es mussten komma com genau
wiederzugeben durch den satz die
tatsache dass es einen kurzschluss gab
verursachte das ist der fall war dass es
ein brand gab das sind jetzt sehr sehr
different diffizile unterscheidungen
jetzt müssen wir einfach mal überlegen
was ist jetzt der unterschied ob wir
jetzt sagen der kurzschluss verursacht
in brand also hier muss jetzt
dem komma sein oder in anführungszeichen
oder sagen die tatsache dass ist ein
kurzschluss gab verursachte dass es der
fall war dass es ein brand gaben
das zweite sind jetzt alles sagen
tatsachen ja offensichtlich
täglich geschieht oder siegen so fern
ist
erstens nur ein dieser ist zwar nicht so
satt und man kann zeigen die tatsache
dass ein
medizin und alt er ist ein guter hinweis
also hier der satz geht es dahin
und dieser satz kann wahr oder falsch
seien ja da kann bestehen oder
nichtbestehen diese sachverhalte und im
zweiten haben wir jetzt zwei
sachverhalte sozusagen ja zwei pro
positionen mehr oder weniger die
zusammengenommen sind also die tatsache
dass es ein kurzes gab gab es den oder
gab es die nicht
das sind die wahrheit bedingung und dann
gibt es gab es einen brand oder gab es
kein brand wird zerlegen des normalen 2
war heizwert fähige sachverhalten oder
sätze könnten
das ist offensichtlich ein wichtiger
punkt der damit einher geht ja ja
er sagt ja auch sehr im ersten tat dass
wir hatten
er möchte gar nicht so sehr auf diese
jung toren auf diese kausalen jung toren
ausgeht also hier sieht man jedenfalls
sein bemühen einfach erst mal nur so den
satz zu beschreiben und nichts ist hier
das was dazwischen war das geht und das
geht es ja gar nicht her sondern es geht
um den kurzschluss und brand niemand
denen er genauer beschreibt hatten sie
sich den 2 im ersten nicht geben so dass
es eine logische verknüpfung von 2 den
zweiten platz nicht dass man also wie
gesagt das haus ist um das haus ist
könig das was ist der grünen
wenn man das 1
von 22 stimmen gegen das so zu sagen
dass die ursache zu einer konvention
oder zinsprodukten
für die frage unter besonderem status
ist der tatsächlich nur um
herauszufinden was sagst du es kann ja
eine vermutung seine behauptung sein
dass eine feststellung es sein das kann
alles mögliche sein zweiter spezifiziert
tatsache dass war das habe erst durch
noch uns breit
dieses match
ja man könnte ein guter punkt also der
kurzschluss im wenn man normalerweise
von kurz schluss redet er redet man so
vom kurzschluss das eher der fall war
aber es ist damit noch nicht gleich
gesagt naja ist damit noch nicht gleich
gesagt wenn wir sagen der kurzschluss
dann implizieren wir geläufig allgemein
implizieren würde sagen der kurzschluss
hat das dass der kurzschluss der fall
war dass der kurzschluss passierte und
das wird hier im zweiten satz jedenfalls
noch ein bisschen genauer gefasst
vielleicht also wir haben es dann eben
mit zwei war heizwert fähigen ausdrücken
zu tun gab es jetzt im kurzschluss oder
nicht und gab es den brand oder nicht
im ersten satz ist das alles zusammen
gedacht als eine position
das wäre ein wichtiger unterschied
jedenfalls man nächste mal einfach mal
weiter
alles geht es um den zweiten in zwei
ställen die kursiv gedruckten wörter
einsatz kollektiv da wie und oder wenn
dann dafür spricht sicher auch die
vorstellung kausal gesetze seien
universale kondition aale und singuläre
consult zu deren einsetzung instanzen
wenn man diese gedanken zu ende führt
kommt man jedoch sehr leicht in
schwierigkeit nehmen wir einmal zunächst
einmal an ein kausal gesetzt sei nichts
anderes als ein generalisierte material
ist konditionell als üblicherweise als
standpunkt für uns gilt wenn zwei eine
einsetzung instanz eines solchen
kondition ahls ist haben die kursiv
gedruckt wurde in ihrem text jedenfalls
wie genau die bedeutung des materialen
kondition wenn es ein kurzes gab und gab
es ein brand der aus darauf kann man von
zwei aus sicher schließen aber nicht
umgekehrt den zwei impliziert zunächst
etwas anderes nämlich die konjunktion es
gab einen kurzschluss und es gab einen
brand wir können versuchen 2 und satz 2
als die konjunktion dieser konjunktion
es gab einen kurzschluss und es gab ein
brand und des entsprechenden gesetzes
anzusehen
dies scheint in der tat eine mögliche
interpretation der jugend definition von
ursache seien die oben zitiert wurde
aber dann ist zwei keine einsetzung
instanz des gesetzes mehr und abgesehen
davon dass dieser vorschlag schon in
sich nicht plausibel ist wenn es darum
geht die logische form für zwei
anzugeben und nicht etwa gründe zu
nennen warum man zwei behaupten kann ist
ja auch deshalb sinn weil ihm zufolge
der schluss von der tatsache dass es
einen kurzschluss und ein brand gab und
dem gesetz auf zwei nichts anderes als
die konjunktion diese voraussetzung sein
würde
das ist ein sehr kompliziertes zitat
können sie damit so ein bisschen was
anfangen
also es geht jetzt offensichtlich auch
um diese allgemeinen gesetze also um die
vorstellung kausal gesetz ist ein
universales kondition aale und singuläre
kausal sitze deren einsetzung instanz
was verstehen sie darunter also haben
sie nie was könnte ein universales
kondition sein
hier könnte man das verstehen ja genau
also für alle für alle für alle ickx und
dann hat man setzen wir halt einig sein
und haben wir eben ein fall davon
dann wird das sagt instanziert dieses
gesetz durch einen konkreten fall also
detektiv letztendlich also motors polens
letztendlich wir haben das allgemeinen
gesetz und wir setzen dann ein fall ein
dann folgt daraus eben diese die
konklusion also es geht jetzt
offensichtlich um die frage wie sich
jetzt diese generellen kausal gesetz zu
diesen singulären termini zu diesen
singulären aussagen verhalten
nicht betragen will
also ist es geht halt einfach eine gute
frage ja wie kann man das jetzt sie
haben sich gemeldet
was für welche
oder was für eine funktion der trend von
der frage was der autor status ist das
wirklich ursachen natürlich bedeutet das
zunächst gilt es jemals gelernt was
bedeutet das was ist wenn die logische
funktion des rektors verursacht und ihr
sagt eben zunächst es scheint dass ein
fachmann wenden beziehung aber bei
solchen einsätzen instanz
aber das scheint mich gesamtheit des
zweiten satzes auszudrücken weil da eben
noch die beiden waren das ist
tatsächlich ein postkarten um das ist
tatsächlich
die beiden landesregierungen
das wäre ihr erster fallende reine wenn
dann beziehung offensichtlich und hier
wird es jetzt komplizierter weil wir
jetzt hier eben einmal so ein reizwort
fähigen auszug haben und hier nochmal
diese position habe und das ist halt
eine position dieser erstes hat der ist
nur eine position und wir haben als
hammer halt eine verknüpfung eine
kausale verknüpfung von zwei positionen
ausdrücken würde sagen bedeutet diese
vision zusätzlich dass die wahrheit und
diese konvention dieser datei
und das hat dann noch keine band sondern
dass ich das
als es richtig dass sie gleich dazu auch
im tor mit einigen anderen damit sollen
kammer zu machen und werden vielleicht
auch unsere bedingung aber zwei
instanzen mehr von einem pensionisten
gesetzt
hinzu kommen also alles wird jedenfalls
viel komplexer als der erste satz jetzt
erstmal weiter nehmen wir also an es
gibt ein nichts wahrheit' funktionales
kausal kollektiv wie das von vielen
zeiten vorgeschlagen wird eine
übereinstimmung mit dem begriff von
ursache als bedingung wird das chaos
alle kollektiv also diese verbindung
dieser zwei positionen wie verursachte
als ein konditionelles kollektiv
betrachtet also konditionelles
konstruktiv weder irgendwelche diese
diese wenn dann beziehung betrachtet
allerdings soll es stärker als das
wahrheit' konditionelle kollektiv sein
konzerne kollektiv sein das ist jetzt
erstmal das hier zum beispiel schreibt
also pap verglichen mit der materialen
implikation ist die besondere
eigenschaften der kausalen implikationen
gerade das von der falschheit des anti
cds nicht auf die wahrheit der causa
implikation geschlossen werden kann
sollte dieser er dabei an das kollektiv
aus zwei gedacht haben müsste uns diese
bemerkung seltsam anmuten
denn es ist eine eigenschaft des
kollektivs in satz zwei dass man sowohl
aus der falschheit ist ante cds wie der
des konsequenz auf die falschheit von
zwei schließen kann
works main p ist kausal hinreichend für
kuh ist logisch valencia ist kausalen 3
und daraus wird vielleicht noch
offensichtlich dass man 1 und 2 nicht
analysieren kann wenn man das kausale
kollektiv als eine art konditionelles
kollektiv betrachtet
in der tat zeigt seine bemerkungen nicht
nur dass sein kollektiv nicht das aus
zwei ist sondern auch das ist nicht das
subjektive kausale kollektiv würde
verursachen ist wenn ich müller kitzelte
würde ihnen das zum lachen bringen aber
wenn er nicht lachte würde das nicht
verursachen
das ist nicht der fall ist dass ich ihn
gekitzelt habe
das ist jetzt auch noch mal sehr
kompliziert und weil jetzt hier unten
nämlich auch noch mal so eine art von
tatsache einkommen also würde würde
nicht nur wenige kitzelt haben sondern
wäre es nicht der fall dass ich ihn
nicht gekitzelt habe ja jetzt haben wir
hier also das kurz gesagt geht es hier
um die frage wie wir jetzt dieses dieses
wenn dann also diesen diesen dieses
diesen punkt uhr dieses kausale
kollektiv also das was letztendlich die
zwei positionen verbindet in diesem
beispiel hier also die tatsache dass ein
kurzschluss gehabt das ist dann das
kausale kommentiert der usa das ist der
fall war das ist ein brand gehabt wie
man das zu verstehen hat jetzt gibt es
hier also mehrere möglichkeiten also es
gibt es hier einmal dieses material
konditionen
und dann gibt es noch alles ist hier
sagt oder wie man ihn ausspricht
verglichen mit der materialen
implikation dass es die marke
publikation die wir in der logik lernen
dieses wenn dann können sie so eine
wahrheits wer tabelle machen
das ist der fall wenn sie dann im
einfach wahr und falsch einsitzen
da gibt es eine wahrheits wert
verteilung zudem
kondition ahlen kollektiv zu dem
material implikationen ist die besondere
eigenschaft der kausalen implikationen
gerade das von der falschheit des anti
cds also von dem wenn nicht auf die
wahrheit der kausalen implikation
beschlossen werden kann
somit soll mal kurz die wahrheit' wert
verteilung bei seiner materialen
implikation anschauen das wäre
vielleicht noch mal wäre vielleicht
nicht schlecht wenn wir das nochmal hier
uns kurz etwas genauer ansehen
ich mache jetzt einfach mal hier dieses
adam g
und das ist dann in der mitte ist dann
sozusagen die das ergebnis in die mich
recht erinnere
jetzt gibt gibt mach mal hier war und
war was kommt dann in der mitte aus
ja gehen wir einmal durchmachen jetzt
mal hier mal falsch und hier und falsch
gibt es auch im fall
da haben wir alles aufgeregt ihr wisst
ihr war ein kommen und was ist denn
falsch dass
das ist also diese war heizwert
verteilung dieser materialien
implikation wie wir sie in der in der
universitären logik behandelt und darauf
spielt er jetzt also an verglichen mit
der materialen indikation dass die
materialien blick aktion ist die
besondere eigenschaft der kausalen
integration das von der falschheit das
alte cds also die falschheit das andere
cd ist nicht auf die wahrheit der
kausalen indikation geschlossen werden
kann
nämlich auch wenn wir hier den fall
haben dass das falsch ist
in beiden fällen unabhängig jetzt von b
wenn a falsch ist kommt hier beide male
wer aus bekommen wir beide male dass wir
hier
und das hat jetzt hier dieser art ab das
gilt jetzt nicht bei einer beim kausalen
konditionen
es müssen wir uns überlegen wie wir das
zu verstehen haben ja weil es diese
dieses konvention in dem war also das
gibt mir den beantworten
also ist diese kondition
dieses geht alles bei gm
und dann sagt der mann ganz groß und so
eine vision kamera oder nicht soll dann
solche studie
eine alte regel seien daher das kann gar
nicht ausschließen aber es kann man so
nicht
auch sowie
das ist verschieden
und 7
ja ich glaube dass ein wichtiger punkt
dass wir uns das noch mal hier überlegen
welche also er bekommt jetzt hier die
als er will jetzt praktisch deswegen
diese diesen satz hier so umformulieren
diesen ersten indes die tatsache dass
ein christus gesagt das ist der fall
werth ist ein band gab dass wir eben des
andere cds kurzschluss die tatsache dass
ein kurzes gibt und dass ein brand gibt
dass man das war heizwert fähig
analysieren kann dass man das also hier
in so eine form bringen kann das scheint
der grund zu sein warum man das jetzt im
sinne dieser tatsachen analysieren weil
die wahrheit' wird fällig sind
ein kurzschluss ist nicht wahr heizwert
fähig ein ereignis ist nicht wahr
heizwert finde ich ein ereignis kann
nicht wahr und falsch sein das ist der
grund ein ereignis ist eigentlich schon
ein bestehender sachverhalt müsste man
eigentlich sagen also ein ereignis ist
eigentlich immer schon war das war ihr
punkt zurecht sie darauf hingewiesen
haben warum denn ereignis ist doch immer
schon war klar aber er möchte jetzt eben
den fall haben das ein sachverhalt oder
eine position wahr oder falsch sein kann
und das haben wir beim ereignis nicht
ein ereignis ist eben immer schon machen
fallen eben dass ein bestehender
sachverhalt ist ein ereignis ist ein
chip davon wie der kommilitone sagte
dadurch können wir jetzt eben diesen
satz eben noch ein bisschen genauer
beschreiben und im wahrheit' werte
vergeben für das andere cds und für das
konsequenz und dann schauen und jetzt
hatte die kommilitonin glaube ich zu
recht darauf hingewiesen dass also sonne
wenn wir eben kausalität so verstehen
nach diesem modell hier dass wir dann
wenn jetzt also ja wenn wir das jetzt in
diese form bringen dass das dann
irgendwie nicht mehr ganz einleuchtet
hier das dann war auskommen also wenn
ihr jetzt wenn es falsch ist dass es ein
die auf die proposition es gab einen
kurzschluss falsch ist wenn das nicht
der fall ist das dann das ganze war sein
soll
was könnte denn die intuition sein dass
er bei einer material implikation als
wenn adern b und sagt eben nicht das ist
falsch
dass man dennoch auf auf war schließt
was ist was ist so die intuition das
essen problem das ist in der logik ist
das vergeben student glaube ich ein
problem das man dass man eher dazu neigt
das dann hier falsch reinkommt oder was
anderes was könnte so der grund sagen
haben sie eine intuition warum könnte
man das ganze dann als war ansehen
nicht geben können die aussage wenn
armee ist nur falsch
das ist ja ein guter punkt aber immer
können doch noch das prinzip ex fall zog
quodlibet signatur verwenden oder als
aus dem falschen können wir halt alles
folgen
ja das wäre auch wohl noch der fall ex
fall so gut liegt also aus dem falschen
kann ich alles reduzieren ja verfolgt er
alles also folgt auch petr aus denn wenn
eben nicht wenn das falsch ist oder das
war zum einen gedanken noch so ein
bisschen aber sie haben natürlich auch
nicht das ist natürlich nur dann falsch
wenn ich eben sagen habe aber nicht b
kommt dann ist das ganz klar falsch aber
wir haben eben noch dieses sie
orientieren sich jetzt hier nur an der
falschheit es sagen es gibt eben nur
eine genaue bedingung für die falschheit
dieses konditionell und es ist die und
daraus folgt dass alles andere war sein
muss
richtig zu sagen ja es natürlich gerät
genau diesen guter punkte man könnte
aber jedenfalls richtig also man sagt
das ist eben dann nicht der fall und wir
behaupten es aber gerade und daraus
erfolgt dann eben das ist ebenfalls ist
die frage ist halt immer wie man davon
ausgehen dass es halt nicht regnet und
gutes könnte natürlich auch was anderes
dann zu be geführt haben dass die
multiple multiple realisierbarkeit
wenn also nicht dann könnte eben auch zb
verursacht haben das mag auch noch so
eine position dahinter zahlen ja aber
jedenfalls bekommen wir probleme mit
seinem materialen konditionen tvi
kausalität aussagen zu modellieren
obwohl er jetzt ja wenn wir jetzt auf
dieses zitat normen gekommen
ja dann sagt hier
hier scheint er jetzt ja wie verhält
sich jetzt hier davidson these zu dieser
dieser materialien implikationen was
will jetzt dazu sagen was ist seine
these jetzt ist die jetzt angemessen für
diese wir haben jetzt nicht bei diesem
satz 2 nicht mehr mit einer mit einem
bloßen konditionen zu tun weil das
konditionell wäre ja nur dann kommt das
darauf folgt das konsequent wir haben es
mit einem kausalen jung tor zu tun also
es verursacht ja die frage ist können
wir die verursachung verbindung zweier
proposition können wir die so analysiert
wahrheit' funktional wie wird es bei
einem materialen implikation können und
was sagt er jetzt hier auf diesen
einwand von diesen papieren
eine kausale betroffen
das reale integration deswegen ist ein
testament sagen es gibt sehr wohl
beiträge das wissen sehr wohl was würde
passieren wenn alle geben zu dem ganzen
amg das wiederum eine weitere chance hat
aber eine andere welt als die
materialien
version und ich glaube das ist so ein
bisschen seien seien voraussagen nur
weil es nicht diese bewegung hat genau
ein sekretär des wird daraus nicht
folgen
die causa leben und für diese kausale
also ihr
diesmal klappt
also die möchte ich heute noch etwas
dazu schreiben 22 konditionen hat ben
ali und bmw und dann geht es also
durchaus den falschen nicht genau das
bei dir wechselmöglichkeiten und zwei
davon sind leiden unter dem feierlich
zum beispiel den plan
das ist falsch
also haben
dann sollten
ja also es ist eine sehr komplexe
angelegenheit wie sie sehen diese
material indikation ist nicht ohne
diese überlegung zeigen dass das
kollektiv aus zwei und damit auch das
aus 1 nicht wie oft angenommen wird ein
wie immer geartetes konditionelles
kollektiv sein kann die überlegungen
zeigen jedoch nicht dass zwei nicht die
logische form der singulären aus
pauschalen aussage darstellt und die zu
zeigen muss ein stärkeres argument
beigebracht werden was meiner meinung
nach auch möglich ist es ist
offensichtlich dass das kollektiv zwei
nicht wahrheitskommission a list den
zwei ändert sein war heizwert wenn man
die reihenfolge der in 2 enthaltenen
waren sätze ändern ich desto weniger
wird der wahrheit' wert solcher sätze
wie 1 und 2 nicht geändert wenn man in
ihnen singuläre ausdrücke durch andere
ersetzt die die gleiche extension haben
wenn die ursache von maiers tod sein
sturz von der leiter war
und wenn meier der erste mensch auf dem
mond war dann war der sturz von der
leiter
die todesursache des ersten menschen auf
dem mond war
und wenn die tatsache dass es im
mueller-stahl gebrannt hat die ursache
dafür war dass das schwein gegrillt
wurde und will aus stahl das größte
bauwerk von neudorf ist dann war die
tatsache dass es mit dem größten bauwerk
von neudorf gebrannt hat die ursache
dafür dass das schwein gegrillt wurde
wir müssen also von der gültigkeit
dieses prinzips das prinzip der
extension ahlen ersetzbarkeit ausgehen
sicher ist auch dass wir den wahrheit'
wert von sätzen wie zwei nicht ändern
können gehen wir die in zwei
eingebetteten sense durch logisch
äquivalente setzte ersetzen
also jetzt geht es hier was besagte
nochmal das extension aale das prinzip
der extension ahlen ersetzbarkeit was
ist sind das noch mal ja in einem
gewissen kontext logischen kontext
ich glaube dass es so dass pflege
prinzip wenn wir nicht alles durch das
geht auf gottlob frege zurück dass man
das ersetzen kann ja leibnitz bestimmt
auch ja geht es was ist jetzt hier also
jetzt kann man plötzlich dass eben
ersetzen also mueller stahl ist eben
ersetzt jetzt durch das größte bauwerk
von neudorf
eine sagt nichts ändert sich an diesem
war heizwert diese funktion des satzes 2
wenn wir die extension also wenn wir
eben aber singuläre ausdrücke durch
andere ersetzen wie die extension
extension ist letztendlich die referenz
zur zudem dinge in der welt zu diesem
einzelnen gegenstand
also ich kann eben ein und dieselbe
sache verschieden beschreiben aber sie
referieren eben immer auf dieselbe sache
ja ich kann also sagen über ein und
dieselbe person
sie ist eben der größte mensch der welt
ich kann auch wenn es eben nur einen
gibt einen größten menschen der welt und
ich kann zugleich noch sagen es ist die
intelligenteste wenn es auch dieselbe
wenn es nur eine geben dass eben
extension a leben auf dieselbe person
hinweist ja das ist nicht das problem
aber das kollektiv in zwei ändert den
wahrheit' wert wenn man die reihenfolge
der in zwei alten waren setzte ändert
wie verstehen sie dass die reihenfolge
ändern
nein
ja
ich habe jetzt schon sagen und zwar von
geändert
das ist ein kriterium bei der insel
utoya schon sehr jung der inhalte ist
als wahrheit so dass wir jetzt unsere
regeln diese ganz anderes zu machen
darum ist es ja schon nicht mehr
dasselbe
das eine ist nicht unsere sache zu sagen
dass das nicht
offensichtlich ist das problem ist also
verglichen vielleicht hier mit a und b
wie sehen sie es so kann man das nicht
wieso gibt es probleme mit der
reihenfolge der radsätze also
offensichtlich um das problem von
solchen kondition ahlen wenn wir nur so
beliebige variablen da einsetzen oder
wenn wir es eben mit bedeutungs
tragenden setzen zu tun haben das wäre
jetzt meine intuition das eben wenn sie
jetzt mal den satz hier nochmal sich
anschauen
den zweiten her jetzt setzt trainer mal
das ganze hier um also die tatsache dass
es ein brand gab verursachte die
tatsache dass ein kurzschluss gab
es gibt keinen sinn oder das ergibt gar
keins
ich fahre sie in die andere richtung
gehen
es geht jetzt aber offensichtlich eben
um die wahrheit bedingungen also machen
also er meint wohl hier haben wir es mit
einer gewissen semantik zu tun mit einer
gewissen ordnung und selbst wenn sie
beide war sind bei der ba sind
ja wie verstehen sie das immer noch mal
hier ein bisschen auf diesen ganz zurück
gestanden
hier
denn es 200 sein wird wenn man die
reihenfolge der instandhalter waren
sitze ändert
ja das ist
natürlich kann ich nicht einfach über
vertauschen implikationen
als er tauschen kann man jetzt nicht die
einzelnen bestandteile sondern kann eben
letztendlich nur also extension a lebn
vertauschen die ja er hat er hat jetzt
ein anderes beispiel in diesem satz hat
er jetzt eben bestimmte eigennamen
müller und so weiter und so fort und
müller kann ich natürlich wenn ich
diesen herrn müller oder diese frau
müller meine kann ich natürlich
innerhalb jetzt dieser jeweiligen
position eben müller frau müller
ersetzen durch die reichste frau in
münchen zum beispiel wenn das vom wir da
ist dann kann man es nur eine reichste
frau gibt dann kann ich eben auf dieser
ebene alles sozusagen nicht so sehr
vertikal das wäre sein taktisch oder
vertikal sondern horizontal also
paradigmatisch kann ich dann eben
ersetzen
die frage wäre ob man hier jetzt in
diesem beispiel bleiben könnte
kurzschluss durch was anderes ersetzen
können dann müsste es eben durch eine
andere bezeichnung ersetzen die
denselben sachverhalt heraus macht ja
das war was ganz anderes als das ist
recht trivial dass man es nicht umdrehen
kann man kann eben nicht also auf einer
horizontalen ebene die sachen um ändern
aber man kann sie eben sagen vertikal
paradigmatisch kann man hier was anderes
einsetzen wenn es die selbe extension
hat dann ändert es nichts
betrachten wir die folgenden sechs sätze
die schauen wir uns noch kurz an ist
eine tatsache dass hans hingefallen ist
hansis hingefallen und hans hat sich ein
loch in den kopf geschlagen
das sind aber sehr martialisch setzte
hans ist hingefallen bevor sich hans
einem noch in den kopf geschlagen hat
hans ist hingefallen was die ursache
dafür war dass es der fall war dass ich
hans ein loch im kopf geschlagen hat
franz hat die tatsache vergessen dass
hans hingefallen ist dass hans
hingefallen ist erklärt die tatsache
dass hans sich ein loch im kopf
geschlagen hat
hatte mal anschauen hier das wissen
jetzt hier der unterschied zwischen
diesen sechs sätzen
es ist eine reise ein
hier ist einfach normale edition
genau
genau ja ja
ja also richtig also bei genau richtig
völlig richtig es könnte genau zur
selben zeit zb sein
es ist völlig zeitlos zeit richtig
richtig genau aber was könnte jetzt das
problem bei fünf noch sein bei bevor
was ist jedes problem also warum reicht
das noch nicht aus um kausalen jung tor
auszudrücken genau genau also hier kommt
jetzt wieder das problem bei der von
david hume ins spiel
david hume hatte gesagt es muss eine
kontinuität geben eine raum zeitliche
nähe das aber selbst das reicht
natürlich noch nicht aus selbst wenn
dieses bevor unmittelbar bevor gewesen
wäre würde ich jungs sagen es reicht
nicht aus weil damit bekommt man nicht
die notwendigkeit des übergangs den
existierenden existierende kraft ist in
diesem unmittelbar bevor noch nicht
enthalten ja gehen aber weiter also
jetzt haben wir da praktisch eine
konkretisierung satz nummer sechs hand
ist hingefallen was die ursache dafür
war das ist der fall war
da sich hans ein loch in den kopf
geschlagen hat wie sieht es damit aus
er ist
wir haben
das ist jedenfalls jetzt wieder so
formuliert im sinne dieser positionen
also was die ursache war
was die ursache war ist dass hans
hingefallen ist und das war wiederum
dass dieser das ganze event wie satz
nummer 2 scheint mir zu sein dass ja ich
habe halt hier so ein bisschen was die
ursache dafür war
also ist richtig das eigentliche
ereignis aber man spricht von dem
ereignis fast schon so ein bisschen
professional die tatsache dass hans
hingefallen ist was dieses war es diesen
relativ wohnung das relativ pronomen
scheint mir fast schon so ein bisschen
darauf hinzuweisen dass das hier nicht
mehr ereignet nicht als ein ereignis
aufgefasst werden muss man als seine
position gegen diesen war
ja aber gut ein wichtiger ist ein guter
punkt aber jeden fall hier ist es dann
und klar hier ist dann ganz klar das ist
der fall war dass sich hans ein loch im
kopf geschlagen hat das ist alles jetzt
wieder im sinne dieser pro positionen
formuliert wie es eben davidson so gerne
hat rund 7 franz die tat zu vergessen
dass hingefahren sind ihm gefallen ist
und sagt dass hans hingefallen ist
erklärt die tatsache dass sich hans ein
loch in den kopf geschlagen hat die sind
jetzt nicht mehr nur kausal zu verstehen
des 7
überhaupt nicht und der satz 8 ist wir
verstehen uns als 8 aus einer kausalen
perspektiven
hier
genau das erste stichwort kausale
erklärung expedition das ist so ein
bisschen dieser erklärt frage ist das
eine kausale erklärung ist darin die
kausalität zwischen hinfallen und loch
in den kopf schlagen impliziert ja
das ist genau die frage ist ist es ist
erklärung immer kausal bezogen wie
würden sie sehen ja also sie sagen nein
sie würden sagen nein könnte erklären
auch einen anderen zusammenhang zweier
pro positionen als den einer kausalen
erklären wenn sie jetzt mal war ist wenn
sie wahr ist aber wenn sie jetzt wahr
wäre wäre dann erklärung eben kausal zu
verstehen
sie schließen sich nicht aus beide
erklären versteht es immer geben
und beide können vernünftige erklärung
seiten also wie so vieles
als würden seine erklärung von
okay sie würden also sagen es als 8 und
6 sind also also der satz 6 folgt nicht
außer acht würde sagen ja also es folgt
nicht daraus also sie würden sagen dass
acht impliziert nicht satz 6 ok
nicht notwendigerweise ja ja ich keine
visionen aber ich habe nicht gesagt dass
wenn die erklärung macht richtig ist
also ist irische regierung dann ist die
6 manche ursachen tatsächlich
veränderungen kann ich mir nicht
erklären
also er schreibt nicht das hansmann es
verstehe ich als erklärung wenn man das
erklären sind vor allem das ist die
richtige verknüpfungen und wenn es dann
[Musik]
okay eine ganz spannende frage also das
ist jetzt pause lag station da gibt es
auch einen aufsatz glaube ich auch von
donna davidson council expedition also
ist erklärung immer pauschal nicht
unbedingt als erklärung natürlich nicht
erklären kann zum beispiel auch analyse
seien einfach nur analyse eines begriffs
zum beispiel wenn ich sagt junggeselle
ist eben unverheiratete mann das auch
eine erklärung da ist aber gar nichts
mit qualität zu tun
immanuel kant wird es sagen das ist ein
synthetischer satz
hier wird werden zwei sätze synthetisch
verknüpft und nicht analytisch verknüpft
und es kann natürlich auch formen der
erklärung geben die nicht synthetisch
sind die eben rein analytisch sind also
insofern das war wahrscheinlich into
ihre intuition so ein bisschen
wobei wenn man das so liest eben ist
eben im hinfallen von hans analytisch
schon dass das sich ein loch in den kopf
schlag enthalten
oder andersrum das ist auch so ein
bisschen die frage
welchen bezug zu dem was wir in der tat
ich glaube das sind wollte das nicht und
zeit
die beiden folgen
ja ja
von meinem
und ich meine
und ich kann mir noch hinaus müsse
zusagen dass die beides diese gesagt
hatte im selben netzwerk
egal ob vor oder nach b statt dh familie
konzentrieren wollen als nur
und was kann es nicht
die tabelle
etwas werden anders gestaltet von dem
selbst die kondition
allerdings an der tafel also nicht
hinreichend
richtig das ist auch noch ein wichtiger
punkt das war diese dieses dieser punkte
sagte wir können es das ändert sich die
reihenfolge weil also hier ist ja noch
nichts gesagt darüber dass a vorbei war
das ist damit der nicht nicht gesagt
dass das ist überhaupt keine zeitlich
aussage wir bräuchten also eine zeit
logik letztendlich also eine nicht nur
wahrheit also eine wahrheits funktionale
aussage die aber eben zeitliche relation
auch noch einschließen oder sensibel ist
und ich haben wir keine informationen
dass das es dass es davor ist ne das
sagen nicht unterhalten
wir brauchten sie eine zeit logik
eigentlich noch so ein bisschen
[Musik]
unser ding ist zum beispiel wenn man
sagen würde dass hans huber laut focus
ist erklärt dass er gestern zu spät
gekommen
vorgestern gefunden was eben mit zwei
bohrungen die regeln erklären er
wirklich guter hinweis wir sehen es die
anderen kommilitonen das heißt es
abschließend dann ist es in unserer
gruppe
also seid die vollen kosten
immer mehr patienten
wie man dieses erklären verstehen jetzt
mal kurz weiter also wir haben jetzt
hier jedenfalls schon ein bisschen also
diese verbindung wird problematisiert
wenn wir die sätze drei und vier durch
äquivalente sätze oder die ihnen
erhalten singulären ausdrücke oder
prädikat durch solche gleich extension
ersetzen ändert sich der wahrheit' wert
von 3 und 4 nicht also zum beispiel hans
können wir ersetzen durch eine beliebig
antreten ausdruck zb den größten man
münchens wenn das denn ist oder den
kleinsten mann oder die kleinste frau
die größte frau nähert sich der wahrheit
von drei und vier nicht hier herrscht
extension ali cetin 7 und 8 herstellt
gegen intentional i tät den analog
ersetzung der sätze oder in den sätzen
bewahrt die wahrheit nicht immer genau
auf sieben und acht zurück
was jetzt hier das problem
wenn ich jetzt hans er setzte durch der
größte mann münchen
warum ist das jetzt dann nicht mehr
wahrheit' erhalten nicht extension von
hans ersetze ich könnte jetzt also ich
ganz oben wie hier
hans ist hingefallen der größte mann
münchens ist hingefallen wo sich die
größte mall münchens ein loch im kopf
geschlagen hat das war es wert erhalten
die extension ist dieselbe die extension
macht keinen unterschied
wenn ich jetzt hier sagte hans dass der
groß größte man münchen ziehen gefallen
ist was ist dann das problem hier sagt
hier ändert sich der wahrheit' wird das
ist nicht mehr wert erhalten warum
der extension genau wissen was das ist
genau genau das ist nicht das was er
sich denkt dabei das als ein problem und
jetzt macht auch noch so seltsam warum
ist jetzt achter ja auch intentional
also nicht extension
das hat ihm gefallen ist erklärt die
tatsache dass der größte mann münchen
sich ein loch im kopf gehauen hat warum
sollte es jetzt intensiver sein
[Musik]
formulierung einem der einführung der
wahrnehmung danach glaube ich daran dass
ich angekommen
es könnte der tatsächlich an sinnfreien
aber ich halte diese jemand anderen
mich dass hans dass die persönlichen
seite
also wir umfallen
aber ich denke dass jemand anders die
frage ist halt die sie setzen ist jan
dem erklären an hat dieses erklären das
ist okay und dann wird intentional dann
ist eben dass die der sind sozusagen
dann entscheiden und nicht nur die
referenz mit pflege wird sie das sagen
ach ja
passen nicht zusammen
[Musik]
sie würden sie würden sagen das sei
eigentlich genauso funktionieren würde
wie satz 5 oder so dass man eben hans
austauschen kann durch andere
bezeichnungen die denselben gegenstand
in der welt bezeichnet ja das ist das
ist ein guter punkt also dass sie haben
jetzt ist sie sagten wir nicht haben
es geht hier um ereignisse obwohl das
natürlich auch
[Musik]
lang hat ist immer chancen wenn sie für
frege transmit kollektion kommt ist es
ist also von attributen wie wir diesen
link zu schreiben uns hinein hans nennen
aber die attribute sind also unabhängig
von den tatsächlichen hand
aber wir können nicht wissen dass sie
sagen jetzt mit dem erklären kommt eben
dass wir müssten wissen hinein
sie würden sagen dieser erkläre das
erklärt prädikat hier
das macht das der ganze kontext
intentional sensitive wird und nicht
mehr rein extension ahl beschrieben
werden kann
dieses erklären dieses verstehen sie
wird sagt das impliziert ein subjekt
auch das verständnis
franz der welt umwelt mitwelt und der
angst und dem ich denke dann den ich
denke wenn sie nicht okay okay sie hat
nicht diese bereits das display das
nicht verrücken kann das über sind klein
selbst soll
genau das hängt wohl mit dem erklären
zusammen
das einfach draußen haben
hatte sich hier noch immer gewillt oder
ja also wir sind mit dem erklären
zusammen und aber auch der hand zu
nehmen sein kann nicht ausgetauscht
werden
es steht ja nicht dass man angst ist
dieses habe ich könnte doch sagen der
größte mann münchen ist das der größte
mädchens hin gefangen
wenn sie sagen wenn sie von der tatsache
dass sprechen dann ist damit nicht
gefällt damit also dann wird nicht der
tatsächliche hansen auf dem kopf sondern
dass auch sie mit hans verknüpfen
also ihr bild von hansen oder den eltern
dass dieses mit diesen personen
ich habe mir bei dass die erklärung also
dass die beiden verknüpften grund dass
ihre unterschieden sind und nur dann ist
die selbe referent und würden dieselben
referenten
dieselbe extension würden sie sagen also
also dieselbe intention diese intention
dann dieselbe semantik ja eine spannende
frage mir leuchtet so nicht ganz ein
aber ich sehe ihren punkt auf jeden fall
also und sagt davidson sagt das ja auch
ne werden sagt das ist jetzt hier kein
extension ahler kontext mehr sie noch ja
würdest du auch
also die besten möglichkeiten der welt
entsprechen aber nicht dasselbe
also die tatsache dass das depot in blau
ist nicht das gleiche wie der wertung
und ich kann den schwung basteln wir ein
wort ohne dass ich den bogen verändern
würde und dass einige sich bezeichnete
das und besonders das was bezeichnet
wird und angst im recht ist die
bezeichnungen das und hans das
bezeichnete unkenntlich bezeichnung
in hat sich das gezeichnete also nicht
nur die bezeichnung hessen
überhaupt geld gehabt hätte
ja und natürlich auch noch alles gut
jetzt die frage nach den bedingungen
also weil das hinfallen alleine dann ist
natürlich wieder wieder randbedingungen
hängt also das wäre das hinfallen wäre
schon die ursache aber wir müssten dann
eben nach der in ausbildung noch
randbedingungen hin als zum beispiel
biete nicht die fehlende sprinkleranlage
wäre der fehlende helm und dir das
brennmaterial wäre hier der harte boden
oder einstein
das wäre dann so zu verstehen ja also
spannende frage sehen also konzentriert
sich ganz auf die die die die logik
semantik dieser setzte intention analoge
ersetzung der sätze oder in den sätzen
der wahrheit nicht immer 5 und 6
scheinen dazwischen zu legen ist zwar
die ersetzung singuläre ausdrücke durch
extensive ausdrücke wahlzeit erhalten
die ersetzung der zzf event setzte ist
es aber nicht
allerdings handelt es sich hier wie er
vor beispiel zwei gerade gesehen haben
und was somit auch für sechs gilt um
eine unhaltbare zwischenposition
schließen wir das noch kurz dann gehen
wir am ende noch ein bisschen auf lewis
ein
der entscheidende punkt der sich aus dem
bisher gesagten ergibt ist dass wir
streng zwischen ursachen und den
merkmalen unterscheiden müssen auf die
wir stoßen wenn wir diese kennzeichen
und zwar und also zwischen der frage ob
eine aussage wahrheitsgemäß sagt das
ereignis ein anderes verursacht hat und
der zusätzlichen frage ob die ereignisse
in einer solchen weise charakterisiert
sind dass wir aus gesetzen oder anderen
kausalen wissen detektiv oder anders
schließen können dass die beziehung
kasal es die ursache dafür dass diese
streichholz brennt ist dass es an der
eine reibefläche gerieben geschrieben
wurde heißt es ja aber das war nur ein
teil der ursache
diese streichholz muss sein es muss
genug sauerstoff in der luft sein das
streichholz muss der intensiv genug
gerieben muss es heißen worden sein usw
wir sollten nun diesen einwand ja aber
in seiner bedeutung nicht überschätzen
denn es kann nicht gut möglich sein dass
das reiben nur ein teil der ursache war
dieses streichholz war nämlich
tatsächlich trocken
es war tatsächlich genug sauerstoff
vorhanden und das streichholz wurde
genug geschrieben was einem satz die
ursache dafür dass diese streichholz
print ist dass es an einer reibefläche
gerieben wurde unvollständig ist ist die
kennzeichnung der ursache je mehr wird
diese kennzeichen vervollständigen umso
näher kommen wir vielleicht die
möglichkeit aus der kennzeichnung und
dem gesetz den gesetzen ableiten zu
können
das eine wirkung der beschriebenen art
folgen
also es geht hier um kennzeichnung der
ursache und dass wir dann aus der
kennzeichnung und den gesetzen ableiten
können detektiv das eine wirkung
erfolgen muss
denn sie müssen die ursache eben ganz
genau spezifizieren
das ist das problem jetzt wieder bei
grasser die fein körnigkeit der ursache
so ein kurzschluss den muss kann man ja
auch noch feinkörniger analysieren zum
kurzschluss nach einem kurzschluss hat
auch eine binnenstruktur ein kurzschluss
baut sich auch auf einen kurzschluss da
bräuchten wir jetzt müssen wir jetzt die
techniker frage aber gut ein kurzschluss
hat vielleicht etwas was dann so
explodiert so ein bisschen aber ein
kurzes bahnt sich an
da muss irgendetwas porös werden und das
wiederum hat auch die ursache dass da
jetzt eine materialermüdung stattfindet
oder irgendwie eine korrosion oder ich
weiß nicht was eine überlastung des
netzes
da können wir wieder irgendwelche feine
feineren analysen anstellen
aber er sagt jedenfalls wir müssten die
kennzeichen also die ursache möglichst
exakt kennzeichnen und dann bräuchten
wir noch gesetze und ausdehnen könnten
wir dann die wirkung reduzieren also
möglichst exakte formulierung der
ursache plus diese generellen gesetze
und dann einsetzung und dann die
reduktion
das hatten wir eigentlich schon bei
russell so ein bisschen schrieben und
das problem ist halt wenn wir jetzt die
ursache besonders fein könig haben
können wir sie dann überhaupt noch
einsetzen
wenn sie so individuell ist wie sollen
wir sie dann auch einsetzen können und
ist ja gar kein typus mehr dann ist ja
nur noch das ist ja auch gar kein token
mir dann ist irgendwie etwas total
singuläres was nicht mehr so eine art
beziehung überhaupt ermöglicht mehr
das ist ganz schwer da kommen jetzt
wieder dieses problem mit bereit
die beziehung zwischen einer singulären
kausalen aussage wie der kurzschluss
verursachte brand und den notwendigen
und hinreichende geben scheint kurz
gesagt die folgen seien sie ausführlich
über die ursache kennzeichen umso besser
können wir zeigen dass sie entsprechende
kennzeichnungen hinreichend für das
auftreten der wirkung war
und umso schlechter können wir zeigen
dass sie notwendig war
die ausführlicher wie die wirkung
kennzeichen umso besser können wir
zeigen dass die ursache entsprechende
kennzeichnung notwendig war und umso
schlechter können wir zeigen dass sie
hinreichend hat das müssen wir jetzt
noch ein bisschen hier genauer anschauen
diesen punkt hier das müssen wir das ist
vielleicht zum schluss von davidson hier
noch ein bisschen sinnvoll weil
als wir haben jetzt hier ursache wirkung
b und jetzt geht es darum wie wie sehr
wir dir das jetzt spezifizieren kann
also je ausführlicher wird ihm die
ursache kennt sein also je präziser das
ist also genau diese genau dieser
kurzschluss und genau das und exakt das
umso besser können wir zeigen dass die
entsprechende kennzeichnung hinreichend
für das auftreten der wirkung war würden
sie dem zustimmen wäre das doch noch die
ursache jemand das wäre natürlich die
ganze nannte cds bedingungen wobei wir
natürlich nach mecki ursachen von anti
zinsbedingungen unterscheiden müssen
also mecki sagt ja hier wir haben hier
praktisch die ursache oder hier vw das
so ja und dann folgt die wirkung ursache
ist nur eine konjunktion da drin
beschreiben wir jetzt nur diesen teil
der konjunktion der anti cd ins
bedingungen genauer oder beschreiben wir
eben alles des antigens genau mit dieser
konjunktion aber dann wäre das ja nicht
mehr nicht die ursache oder das hatten
sie sich melden sie hier
also diese ganze konjunktion wäre dann
das ist lockt das ist eigentlich ganz
plausibel wenn wir hier keine weitere
konjunktion mehr anführen können dann
machen wir es natürlich hinreichend wenn
wir noch eine weitere konjunktion
hinzufügen könnten wäre ist nur
notwendig
allerdings ist das was mir das
man würde jetzt sagen ein trockenes
gedrucktes streichholz vielleicht ein
gepresstes streichelzoo wird es als
qualitäten oder so was dieses
streichholz bezeichnen aber das ist
natürlich ein problem weil denken sie
mal wie wollen sie denn bitte den
kurzschluss so qualifizieren als also
wie wollen sie den coaches ein prädikat
zu sprechen dass die sprinkleranlage
fehlt ja das ist richtig und zwar im
sinne von den zehn kategorien von
aristoteles zwei dinar ist sagt ja auch
zum beispiel die hexis also auch die
lage in die relation ist ja eine
kategorie mit der wir einen gegenstand
beschreiben also zum beispiel befindet
sich fünf zentimeter weiter von einem
anderen zustand aber das problem ist
halt wie es dann mit nicht existierenden
sachverhalten aussieht also eben dass
damit nicht tracks nicht existierenden
also mit nicht vorliegen denn zum
beispiel umständen hat das eben jetzt
kein oder präpositionen das jetzt eben
kein sprinkler da ist wie das könnte man
vielleicht auch noch im sinne einer
gewissen relation darstellt aber man
referiert wird gerade auf nichts dabei
wenn diese springt ja nicht da ist
mehr
liebes aus mir werden die abwesenheit
das wäre möglich aber ich glaube dass
wir schon so ein bisschen ganz bewusst
diesen ausschluss von möglichen faktoren
braucht dass man die negation mit rein
dingen muss und ich glaube wenn man
negative prädikat da wird es ein
bisschen schwierig ja aber also ein
guter punkt man könnte das alles jetzt
hier auf beziehen und dann wäre es klar
je mehr konjunktionen wir hier immerhin
machen umso genauer bestimmen wird
ich habe damit ein bisschen probleme
eben wegen dieser negativen negativen am
umstände
weil das geht natürlich nicht
ja ok der gegner hat ja gut dass wir
auch noch gut ja als der rentner als der
relation dass man als als eine relation
zu einer sprinkleranlage definiert
der pro jahr eine negative beschreibung
ja ja wobei wobei in der sprinkleranlage
ja nicht nur nicht auf derselben ebene
ist die ein volk das streichholz war
gespickt anlage ist sehr praktisch
kausal konstruiert um etwas zu vermeiden
und ja also das ist eine wäre reaktiv
ihres wird es wäre als ein aus lösungs
verhältnis ich sehe noch ein bisschen
auf einer anderen ebene aber auch eine
generell und eben haben sie glaube ich
auch recht dass man es noch reinpacken
kann ja das ist
ja man müsste es dann eben definieren
als eine komplexe relation wie sie
sagten eben in einer ausreichenden
distanz zu solchen vermeidenden faktoren
ja genau ich könnte es mir könnte ist
wissenschaftlich ziemlich genau
beschreiben hier seine konjunktion okay
jetzt haben wir jetzt nicht viel
gesprochen jetzt möchte ich noch mal
ganz kurz auf diesen netten herrn
eingehen und zwar ist dass der besagte
david luiz der ist nicht allzu alt
geworden nur 60 jahre
und der hat einen aufsatz geschrieben im
alter immerhin von 32 mit dem ticken
korsischen und wir haben hier in
deutschen texten ich möchte zum schluss
noch ganz kurz rein lesen dass wir hier
einfach auch noch ein bisschen schon
eine partizipation haben also
mich interessiert oder uns sollte hier
interessieren wie wenn man die causa
relation contra faktisch analysieren
kann weil der sac nämlich david hume an
einer stelle in seinem nicht in seinem
traktat und seinen clan seine
untersuchungen da sagte es und dann
welche ontologie liegt lewis ansatz
zugrunde
das war alles fragen und jetzt lese nur
ganz zu beginn noch hier diesen punkt
jung definierte die kausalität gleich
zweimal nicht in seinem traktat zum
dienst im kreml er schrieb wir können
eine ursache definieren als ein objekt
auf das ein anderes folgt wobei allen
objekten die dem ersten ähnlich sind
objekte folgende dem zweiten ähnlich
sind das ist also jetzt ein konditionen
oder mit anderen worten hätte das erste
objekt hätte es das erste objekt richtig
geben dann hätte das zweite nie
existiert und das ist jetzt wie sie alle
wissen aus der logik heraus eigentlich
falsch was je nachdem wie man es liest
ja also also kausalität ursache ein
objekt dass ein anderes volk und da
kommt so eine art von regula ried rein
dann b sagte oder wenn jetzt die frage
wie man oder zu verstehen hat
genau das ist richtig genau oder mit
anderen worten das kann man jetzt so
lesen als ob es dasselbe wäre das mit
anderen worten hätte es das erste objekt
nicht gegeben also nur dann wäre auch
das zweite nicht gegeben und das stimmt
natürlich nicht weil wir natürlich b
multipel realisieren können ihr könnt
wie auch realisieren durch zum beispiel
als es stimmt nicht dass ist das ist
nicht richtig sagen da das ist praktisch
äquivalent praktisch mit mit bin nicht b
dann nicht aber nicht mit wenn nicht
oder nicht mehr die contra position aber
das gilt natürlich nicht das ist ein
typischer anfängerfehler
die logik und jetzt ist die große
debatte hat mir einfach nur denkt hat
die um einfach die logik nicht gekonnt
weil das folgt daraus natürlich nicht
weil ich natürlich b auch durch
realisieren kann
das folgt daraus nicht oder wollt ihr
damit was anderes sagen ja
darum diesen pausen
dann wäre es eben dann wäre das eben
hier so eine art fast schon notwendig
und hinreichend dann dürfen eben doch
kein die konditionen genau und dass das
kann man eigentlich nur dann auflösen
wenn man wie konditionell macht also mit
könnte es jetzt so auflösen dass man
sagt er meint eigentlich insgesamt wie
konditionell weil dann würden natürlich
beide sachen zu treffen aber er hat ja
eigentlich hier behauptet dass eben aus
dem konditionell also wenn alan b das
daraus das wollt ja sonst müsste man
sich eben mit dem konditionell behelfen
das wäre dann glaube ich ihr vorschlag
dass ich sagen ist es eben genau dieses
genau dieses nur dieses nur diese
wirkung
ja sie haben sich noch melden
dies bestätigte die kassen endlich sind
nicht identisch sein
also das also
wenn die fdp ist nicht das geben keine
aussage wenn nicht dann nicht
und ich glaube dass also dass man das im
kontext einer systemisch schon verstehen
dass er sagt dass die notwendigkeit der
wahl können
kommt aus unserem stand das gratis
notwendigen 115
genau das ist richtig der erste satz ist
noch keine streng genommen keine keine
kausale aussage sondern der regular riet
erst mal und nur so ein zeitliches folgt
also das wäre schon zu stark wenn man
das als ein konditionell lesen würde
aber es liegt erstmal auf der hand
natürlich so ein bisschen weil er eben
die frage hätte ist das erste objekt
nicht geben man hätte das zweite nicht
existiert das hat so ein bisschen eine
kausale implikationen aber sie doch
wichtig
ja logisch
ihr habt es ist ein ganz großer britta
torische frage weil es gibt eben diesen
frühen der ewig jungen den ganz
radikalen das ist der autor der das
traktat street hieß das haben wir
gelesen und dann gibt es noch einen
etwas späteren der vision in den kreis
und aus denen ist dieses zitat wo er von
kausalität selbstverständlicher redet
als er es in dem traktat getan hat also
er wird liberaler was den
qualitätsbegriff angelangt er ist nicht
mehr so radikal wie im traktat wir sehen
falls eine riesen debatte und viele
lesen ist jedenfalls so viele sagen ja
eigentlich ist es doch eigentlich ist es
doch ein widerspruch
man kann es aber es auch so lesen dass
junge mir einfach zwei formen benennt
wie wir einfach über kausal reden wir
reden auch irgendwie so dass wir sagen
ihm kontra dem kontra faktischen sinn
dieses die contra faktisch rede ist wird
dieser zweite satz hätte das erste
objekt es nicht gegeben dann hätte es
das hätte das zweite nicht existiert ist
eine contra faktische rede und diese
contra faktische reden die ist jetzt für
david luiz diesen herren hier besonders
wichtig das ist alles ein großes ding
dreht und contra faktische sachverhalte
und das wollen wir jetzt in der nächsten
sitzung ausführlich besprechen das war
es nur ein kleiner vorgeschmack machen
sie sich mal gedanken wie sieht's aus
mit der vision hat er hier wirklich
einen logischen fehler begangen oder
kann man nicht das so interpretieren als
ob wir hier einfach grausam wenn wir
über causales verhältnisse reden auch
immer so eine contra faktische redeweise
mit ins spiel bringen das würde wenn wir
das als ein konditionell lesen würden
dann so ein bisschen raus laufen wie so
ein b konditionen das wäre dann so eine
möglichkeit aber wir müssen noch mal
genauer darüber diskutieren wir machen
das in der nächsten und letzten sitzung
des semesters und wir werden dann noch
zum abschluss etwas diesen herrn kim mit
hinzunehmen über seine nicht kausalen
relationen dann bis zur nächsten sitzung